The Joe Rogan experience. Are you
fully committed to the beard now? Yeah,
I want to keep it as long as I
can. [inaudible] man, you know,
as trim to trim a little,
I trim it a little bit. Uh,
I just like the lady who cuts my hair
trims it every like four weeks when I go
in for a haircut,
but I don't touch it at all.
I'm afraid if I tried to trim it I
would just ruin it. But I've love,
love having a beard.
Why do you love having a beard is like,
it's like sunglasses for the bottom half
of your face. Ah. You know what I mean?
Hide from the world kind of. Yeah. Like
it's, it chills me out a little more.
Yeah. Especially on stage.
[inaudible] you're under the lights,
you know? Uh, and I'm, I,
my lip would study a little bit sweaty
and I'm thinking about my lip and I'm
like, should I wipe this? Should I move
it? And then I start to sweat more.
But now that I have the beard and
mustache, my lip gets a little sweaty.
You can't tell. So I don't get more
anxious. Uh, interesting. Yeah.
So you used to like think, boy, there's
a little couple of beads. The upper lip.
Yeah. And I'm like, can they see it?
Should I wipe? Is it like too much?
If I'm wiping, I drives me crazy.
You know, it gets me boogers.
If I think I have a booger,
like, like what is going on
with my nose? What is that?
Is that a booger shit?
Can they see that? Oh,
I check for sure before I go on stage.
There's always approve your check. But I,
I'm so animated and I'm
always yelling and screaming.
I'm always worried that something is like
hanging off the tip of my nose. Yeah.
And the people in the front row can't
even enjoy it. Like, what the fuck man?
Your nose, Bro. I've never had that. I've
had like definitely a fly down situation.
Oh, you never, uh, never, never
like a booger that ruin the show.
This is the two things that people
love to laugh at. Your fly down.
And if you put a beer down on stage
and the foam comes over the top,
like your beard's coming.
Ooh,
those are those things. Right.
[inaudible] hi. Humor. Yeah. High Humor.
Sweat. Like, like weird
sweat stains. Like, um,
when I've done specials speaking,
which Anthony Jessalyn looks new comedy
special comes out tonight. I here. Yep.
This evening. Midnight. I guess Netflix
does it. Yeah. Excited. Very excited. Wow.
I've been seeing your set. It's
fucking fantastic. Thank you. Thanks.
I think this is the best, uh, I've ever
done, so I'm uh, I'm pumped for it.
So beautiful thing about comedy, man.
Keep working, keep paying attention to it.
You get better at it,
you know, really. I mean,
Dom Irrera and I had this conversation
just a couple of months ago.
He looked Joe, he goes, I'm
never been better. He goes,
I'm fucking a thousand years old because
I've never been better at comedy. Yeah.
As long as you don't quit, you don't,
you don't, you don't ever get worse,
I don't think. Right. You don't,
as long as you don't give up because
some guys don't quit, but they give up.
Exactly. Yeah. They just go through
the same material every single time.
You're like, what are you
doing here? You're just like,
you're just trying to get out of the
house. You're not trying to get better.
I was a little of that. Yeah. Yeah.
It's like if you're not right, that's,
I guess that's a difference between
also guys who put out specials or I say
women too or, and people who don't. Some
people just don't put anything out. Yeah,
no. Yeah. Once you put it out, like
I put it out because I'm like, I'm,
I'm done with this now it's getting
boring. It's not going to get better.
It's good as I can make it,
but because of that,
then I have to come up with a new hour.
If I did any specific schedule you like
to fall too, right? If I'm correct, I try.
I did it. I did a year in La, like
at the store every night, you know,
and like once a month I do Largo
and try it all out at once.
And then a, at the end of that
year, I had about 40 minutes,
went to clubs for a year
every weekend for a year.
And then once that I
had the hour after that,
then I did a year of theaters and at
the end of that year I taped the special
and, and uh, and was done
with it. So you're on like a
three year plan? Pretty much,
yeah. And that might change, you
know, as I've gotten older, uh,
the idea of a four year plan sounds a
little bit nicer and you have other things
going on that, uh, that it's not
as, I'm not as worried. Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
I was trying,
I think two years seems
to be right for me,
but it might be better to give
it a little more time. Right.
Just a little bit more time to tighten
things up and Polish and you know,
add layers and add extra punch.
It's like,
you know those guys like in
when I started out in Boston,
there was guys that had been
doing the same set forever.
There's pros and cons to
that and the pro is God damn.
They had that shit down tight where it
was just punchline, rapid punchline,
pause, punchline. They knew the,
the economy of words was perfect.
There was no, no fat in the bits they
had. They had tightened all that stuff up.
Yeah.
My one of my biggest fears is like taping
the special and then coming up with
like a great tag. You know
what I mean? Like that.
I want it to be done when I shoot
it because that feeling is awful.
It's the worst. Done that.
Yeah. So by sucks it sucks
back in. I once went back
in my last special thoughts
and prayers I ADR to line.
I like walked off stage and was like,
oh fuck,
I should use this word.
And I,
it just occurred to me in the moment
that I was using the wrong words.
So I went back and 80 yard and you can
obviously tell that it's like me talking
and then it's like clearly a different,
like a different voice. A just one word.
But I had to do ADR stand for, I know
what it means, but what does it stand for?
Jamie knows he's an actual audio guy.
Automated Dialogue Replacement and why
it's automated is lost in my head forever,
but that's what it means. Ah, okay.
I wouldn't have guessed
that in a million years.